[Musique]
enfin
non
peu mal à la dette à condition bien
construit
on est avec cyril aubin merciris bras
elle très bien de cyril c'était johnny
couleurs sur les amis de mallaury nataf
merci d'être là vous aviez le rôle donc
de johnny dans les filles d'à côté voilà
de johnny dans le miel et les abeilles
et de benoît dans les filles d'à côté
que c'est ça une nouvelle file à côté
merci en tout cas avec la série que l'on
se rappelle tous les types de cyril à
qui était incroyable et mehdi merci
médias l'armée dit pourquoi tu cours tu
cherches et mallaury nataf pourquoi tu
cherchais mallaury nataf en fait alors
déjà bonsoir ce soir meilleurs voeux de
bonne année à tous
[Rires]
je m'attendais à celle que je cherche
malheureux nataf et déjà moi même je me
suis posé la question pourquoi les
personnes qu'ils ont travaillé avec
elles ne sont pas ne sont pas partis et
la chercher quand il était dans un état
critique c'est ça aussi la question oui
et donc donc tu la retrouves et pourquoi
pas en fait pourquoi de l envie
peut-être d'être tranquille d'être voilà
de faire sa ligne ben écoute on est
parti la chercher
pourquoi parce que on enlève et des bas
déjà je veux l'aider bien sûr je voulais
l'aider oui j'ai pris contact avec
plusieurs personnes on l'a trouvé un
appartement on l'a trouvé de quoi se
loger de quoi se dévêtir parce qu'on ne
fait plus voir de me mallaury nataf dans
la rue comme ça il y en a dit jim il est
pourquoi l qui mieux qu'une personne qui
a la rue
pour parler de la rue
nous sommes un groupe d'hommes je suis
pas tout seul jésus un petit peu partout
on a monté un projet qui va parler
d'humanité qui va parler de
l'environnement et de cause animale et
on s'est dit pourquoi pas aller voir ma
le riz nataf justement pour casser le
porte parole alors vous l'avez retrouvé
à mallory dans les rues de paris voulait
proposer de l'aide regardez
merci
mallory ne parle pas comme ça vient je
m'étais dit
la nacelle
c'est le plus les amis je lance un appel
parce que j'ai vraiment besoin de vous
ces quelques uns peuvent venir lui
pareil tu peux venir m'aider je vais la
sortir de la rue ça fait trois mois que
je n'ai que je la cherche maintenant je
vais trouver mallory
bien je t'aide bien un stade
c'est vrai que quand on voit ça valérie
banon mais c'est toujours terrible de
voir quelqu'un qui se retrouvent à la
rue qui n'a qui visiblement on l'avait
déjà évoqué avec jean luc azoulay qui
était venu sur le plateau pour expliquer
qu'il avait tendu la main à plusieurs je
vais retour du doigt vers tendu la main
à plusieurs reprises et visiblement
c'est elle vit des moments extrêmement
compliqué je crois qu'on lui a retiré la
garde de ses enfants enfin c'est la
défense d'une femme qui qui se
retrouvent à la rue et qui qui ne saisit
pas non plus les mains tendues mais on
peut pas aider les gens contre leur gré
alors quand il quand ils ne veulent plus
quand il lâche prise et c'est ça fend le
coeur quoi vraiment je suis la ville
hors méditer à la parole elle n'est pas
folle du tout c'est une femme très
intelligente oui bon on l'avait vu il ya
il ya un organisme juste à côté ces
images je suis rentré dedans je me suis
renseigné et j'ai un monsieur qui m'a
dit c'est quelqu'un qui peut l'approcher
cordialement je voulais l'inviter à
manger j'ai même ramené des vêtements je
vais vraiment les 17 sommes là et pour
elle il n'y a pas que les gens il ya des
gens qui disent qu elle vous l'a filmé
comme ça en fait c'est ça la firme
ouais parce qu'en fait on a l'impression
qu'on l'a revu encore plus dans la mer
savoir une autre polémique mois dans 2
les images que je vois pouvez me dire
qu'elle alors je parle franchement c'est
triste ce qui se passe que moi je les ai
adorés à la télé mais où pour moi elle
est bourrée où elle a un problème mental
il faut qu'elle se soigne pas ce que
l'on jette pas des trucs comme ça dans
la rue face cagettes des chaussettes ou
chez pascal est hélas elle traite tout
le monde dans la rue elle parle tout
seul alors on peut me dire oui elle va
très bien à l'intelligente là pour moi
que ces images avons tourné sur les
réseaux les images elle va pas très bien
il faut fouiller leur il faut que ce
soit les ja qui va pas là alors les
images de nos tournées sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya des gens qui ont dit
pourquoi ils évalueront les réseaux
sociaux pourriez me dit encore
alors vous aussi vous êtes acteur vous
êtes à des amis de deux mallaury nataf
qu'est ce que vous pensez que ça
qu'est-ce que vous avez tenu de ses
nouvelles non moi la mer fois que j'ai
vu c'était sur le tournage de on avait
fait une petite apparition sur la
voilà donc on avait les mêmes rapports
que à l'époque sur le miel les abeilles
ont été contents de se retrouver à
l'époque je crois qu'elle habitait avec
quelqu'un et qu'elle repartait sur un
sur quelques épisodes de tournage là sur
cette série là et voilà ça fait trois
ans à peu près d'angers nouvelle cela
vous j'apprends tout ça alors mehdi
céreq alors c'est toi que tu cherches à
aider et c'est qu'il ya plein de gens
qui disent pourquoi la la la la fille
maya césari l'apa ne pas la laisser
tranquille pourquoi en fin de compte au
début j'ai parlé avec elle mais je
voulais l'aider à la fin de compte j'ai
fait un appel à l'aide je suis tombé sur
une femme qui m'a appelé j'ai une
association qui est des sdf des femmes
battues des femmes violentées al majidi
gptd par rapport à ça est-ce que tu
d'accord que j'appelle les pompiers au
début je n'étais pas d'accord je voulais
discuter avec elles faire une approche
amicale mais elle est partie dans des
propos
mais vraiment très très dur m'a dit j'ai
envoyé quand même les pompiers et a
maintenant il ya des forces de l'ordre
qui sont venus ils ont commencé à me
contrôler je fais écouter je ne suis pas
là pour harceler je ne suis pas là pour
lui faire du mal de lui faire du tort
mais je vais juste aider mais c'est
peut-être elle mallaury nataf c'est
peut-être moi ça peut être peut-être
vous je ne changerai pas mon côté j'ai
rien et c'est de vous connaître et des
rêves a pas été d
une femme malade qu'est une femme en
souffrance en fait tout ce qu'elle peut
dire ça sert à rien même si ça peut être
choquant mais elle n'a pas notre
logiciel ça sert à rien c'est une sorte
de voyeurisme un peu crasseux qui
l'accablent encore encore plus et à
300000 sdf va aller vers d'autres sdf
parce que l'album il ya m'inquiète
attention il refusait les 20 pays à
travers le chaleureux il en a que faire
et lui dirai oui non non elle veut pas
elle
comprend l'honnêteté de la démarche de
médias à la base c'est sûr voulait lui
parler l'aider mais c'est vrai qu'elle
déjà moi j'avais beaucoup parlé avec
françois rocquelin quand il avait essayé
une première fois elle avait elle est
retournée dans une équipe françois
rollin c'est un ancien acteur qu'ils
appelaient à prier on ne sait pas de qui
vous parlez ici arrive où on arrive
arrive oui il avait essayé de la
retrouver de l'aider à l'avers trouver
une colocation en 2019 et puis de
nouveau elle était retombée à rue
donckèle est tellement désespérée que
finalement pour elle la russe est devenu
son mode de vie son quotidien et je
pense que elle a été heurtée que dans
son esprit ou la déranger la
cbc sous les deux producteurs lors
vraiment vous l'a jamais assez il a dit
lewis frank il avait il ya verront le
fait mais évidemment elle est sortie
elle a laissé sa et valérie oui
effectivement il était même venu sur ce
plateau expliqué qu'il avait qui m'avait
proposé deux à la fois de l'héberger de
la faire travailler de la faire tourner
et donc très naïvement peut-être les uns
et les autres on s'est dit on va cette
main tendue la permis que elles s'en
sortent et que tout allait bien comme me
l'avait jamais parfait de la terreur on
va avoir comme mallaury nataf on va voir
les images voilà de myherin l'époque il
y avait eu un truc me rappelle c'était
c'était l'histoire de la culotte dans
notre galerie nathalie tf1 un
déferlement regarder
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est laisser les ravages de la télé
mine de rien alors je sais pas du tout
honnêtement si ce sont les ravages à la
télévision parce que est ce que on a
déjà une fragilité et ça ne fait que
l'accentuer je crois pas que la télé
créée ex nihilo comme ça une fragilité
qu'on n'aurait pas avant je pense que
déjà on est fragile et que là dessus
vient se greffer quelque chose qui nous
dépasse et qui fait qu'à un moment ou
pas quand ont trébuché d'entrée de jeu
vraiment et puis on sombre